We touched on privacy in the healthful exercise.
When you saw how patients could specify the subset of their data they wish to share.
In practice, patients still typically sign a form provided on
a clipboard in the waiting room and agree to
share all their medical record data for treatment,
payment and health care operations, so-called TPO.
In simple terms, this allows sharing of
their data with others involved in their treatment,
such as when their doctor refers them to another physician.
It also allows use of their data in claims for payment for services
rendered and for operational purposes such as quality reporting.
Beyond the routine use encompassed by TPO,
there are many secondary purposes for using health data.
These include comparative studies,
policy assessments, and life science research.
These uses of identifiable or so-called protected health information,
PHI, requires specific permission of the patient.
De-identification removes data from privacy rule protections by
eliminating 18 specified fields that could identify the individual patient.
Limited data sets still contain dates for admission,
discharge in service provision,
date of birth, date of death and city state and zip code.
The use of limited data sets for research does not require specific patient permission,
but it does require that the data be treated the same as
PHI since re-identification is possible,
given the inclusion of this temporal and demographic information.
To avoid this, in some circumstances,
researchers randomly alter dates and
other data where this will not compromise its research value.
Genomic data presents special challenges because each patient's genome is unique.
So altering the genomic data can severely compromise it's value.
There is a second approved but less often used method in which an expert,
who may have a statistical mathematical or scientific background,
certifies that the risk of re-identification is very small.
This can also involve some manipulation of
the data so the NORC group at the University of Chicago has developed XID,
a tool shown here that uses
proprietary statistical methods to give data owners the ability
to experiment digitally and refine their desired risk and analytic utility thresholds.